this video was made possible by nordvpn
go to nordvpn.com forward slash vpen and
get a two-year plan at a super discount
more on this in a moment
[Music]
ukraine is now an official candidate for
joining the european union and i'm sure
most of you remember seeing headlines
like this
eu grants ukraine candidate status in
historic moment just as i'm sure all of
you or at least many of you will have
witnessed this historic moment
the flag of the european union is
already flying in the ukrainian
parliament and in some ways this is
hardly surprising both from the point of
view of european political cohesion and
of course from the military point of
view ukraine has done more than enough
to earn official candidate status not
only because of their tireless and
courageous fight against an invader far
superior in strength but also because we
can clearly say that in european
politics there is a clear turning point
following the russian invasion of
ukraine after all ukraine was attacked
precisely when it wanted to be part of
the western family hold on though
because this is visual politic
undoubtedly becoming an official
candidate for membership in the european
community club is a huge boost to the
motivation and confidence of ukrainian
soldiers and population there is no
doubt about it however put on the brakes
a second because the road to integration
will not be an easy one nor will it be a
fast one
no easy route to european union
membership for ukraine profound
challenges posed by countries legitimate
desire to join bloc must be recognized
do you want to know what obstacles
ukraine faces in order to join the
european union will it really be able to
become a member country what are the
main changes it needs to make well
visualpolitik fans in this video we will
answer these and other questions
[Music]
let's be clear joining the european
union is not like joining nato being
part of the community club implies
incorporating a lot of regulations and
making a lot of changes in the law
politics and economy of the candidate
countries for example it took croatia no
less than 10 long years to become a
member state obviously this period is
not fixed and it depends on each country
finland which already had democratic
institutions and an established free
market economy took two years but i
think everyone absolutely everyone will
agree that ukraine is closer to
pre-european union croatia than to
finland
[Music]
for example in order to become a member
of the community club article 2 of the
treaty on european union must be
complied with this is an article that
often ends up being a headache for many
of the countries that want to join the
union
the union is founded on the values of
respect for human dignity freedom
democracy equality the rule of law and
respect for human rights including the
rights of persons belonging to
minorities article 2 of the treaty on
the european union the question is does
ukraine comply with all this well let's
see how shall i put this i think you all
know here on visualpolitik we strongly
condemn the russian invasion and that we
stand in solidarity with ukraine in its
stoic resistance but what can i say we
would not be objective if we were to
present ukraine through rose-tinted
glasses after all if it struggles for
being the poorest country in europe
there must be a reason
[Music]
right today both ukraine's politics and
economy are far from western standards
for example there is a heavy state
intervention in its economy there are
price controls and a handful of
millionaire oligarchs monopolize the
strategic sectors of the national
economy oligarchs who of course in one
way or another tends to be protected by
the political apparatus itself in fact
corruption in the country is rampant
according to transparency international
ukraine is the second most corrupt
country in all of europe after russia
and it cannot be said that there are
many controls in place to try to curb it
all this helps to explain why ukraine is
exaggeratedly poor by european standards
to give you an idea we're talking about
a country whose gdp per capita in 2021
was barely 40 percent of the gdp per
capita of bulgaria which is currently
the poorest country in the european
union and of course with the war things
have gotten much worse
[Music]
the reality is ukraine has to make so
many changes that some experts estimate
that the accession period if it finally
happens may take 10 to 20 years and
eternity now then exactly what are the
main reforms that ukraine has to carry
out in order to become a member country
what are the main obstacles well we're
going to take a look at that right now
but before we go any further are you
aware how necessary it is nowadays to
have a vpn your location device type ip
address browsing history these are just
some of the traces that you leave when
surfing the net that data is incredibly
valuable whether it's to an intrusive
advertiser or a sneaky criminal nordvpn
helps you reclaim your privacy it
encrypts your connection to the internet
so no one can eavesdrop on the websites
you visit and the data you share it also
hides your ip address and location so
snoopers can't track you down and not
only that remember that when you're
using nordvpn you can browse without
borders choosing from over 5 000 ultra
fast servers in 58 countries all around
the world this unlocks a whole world of
contents that you can't access with a
standard provider connection but is
browsing speed affected while using a
vpn well you don't have to worry about
that with nordvpn as it's the world's
fastest vpn according to an independent
study by av test what's more you can use
it on all types of devices android
windows mac linux all with the same
accounts and you can use up to six
different devices don't wait any longer
use nordvpn at home at work on the go to
enjoy non-stop protection by taking
advantage of a special offer for you
lovely visualpolitik viewers go to
nordvpn.com forward slash
v-p-e-n and get a two-year plan for the
price of one soda a month and if you
change your mind after trying it don't
worry nordvpn has a 30-day money-back
guarantee
the difficult european process
let's see if we had to define the
european union perhaps we could do it
with three words bureaucracy and endless
regulations so the so-called accession
process means that countries that want
to join the eu first have to adopt all
eu regulations at once we are talking
about a process that is divided into six
stages formal application for membership
candidate status pre-assession
negotiations ratification and finally
integration well after its ratification
as an official candidate ukraine has now
fully entered the third stage
pre-assession
during this stage ukraine or any other
candidate country has to agree along
with the european commission on the
so-called pre-accession strategy this
strategy consists of setting a series of
guidelines for ukraine to include in its
jurisprudence the administrative
political and economic reforms that will
enable the states to implement european
laws and we are not talking about a
minor change but about more than 130 000
pages of european legislation that
ukraine will now have to introduce into
its political and legal system and that
is obviously a lot a truckload of
legislation and a very costly process of
attempted changes in all structures
within the country
well no one said it was easy of course
the economy is no exception ukraine will
have to turn its economic model upside
down and completely change it in order
to develop a functional free market
economy that can operate without
restrictions in the common market and
this believe me is much easier said than
done
don't forget that ukraine is a country
that has emerged from the former
communist bloc that is the toughest
soviet union and that has never carried
out deep reforms in its system but we'll
talk about all this in a moment the
question now is does ukraine have to
start from zero well the truth is no it
does not have to start from zero but
almost ukraine is associated with the
european union through the association
agreement signed in 2014 and in force
since 2016. under this agreement the
most specialized javelin country in the
world has been gradually implementing
some changes over the past few years
ukraine's eu association agreement
obliges keeve to pursue rule of law
reforms this agreement by the way has a
lot to do with the course of events
[Music]
and you see thanks to this agreement the
ukrainian economy began to pivot from
the east to the west at full speed that
is from russia and the so-called
commonwealth of independent states
towards the european union in fact trade
with the eu bloc already accounted for
more than 40 percent of all ukrainian
exports in 2020 that's eight times more
than exports to russia we are talking
about a process that now with putin's
invasion far from slowing down has
accelerated even more take a look
eu to suspend tariffs on ukraine imports
for one year kiev grateful ukraine eu
signed agreement on liberalisation of
road transport the agreement eliminates
the need for ukrainian carriers to
obtain permits to enter the eu what's
more at last the ukrainian power grid
has been linked to the european grid
check it out
zielenski says ukraine is now exporting
power to eu be that as it may the fact
is that according to ursula von de
lion's own words thanks to this
association agreement ukraine has
already implemented about 70 of european
legislation and principles
for example among many other changes
public procurement processes have been
improved official statistics have been
brought closer to european standards and
a complete reform of the energy market
which until now was totally controlled
by the state has begun even a digital
administration has been developed
[Music]
however let's slow down because this is
ukraine we're talking about and how can
i put it vondelion's figures she doesn't
even believe them herself the gap that
still separates ukraine from european
standards remains plainly and simply
fast if you want some concrete examples
then take a look
earlier we saw that according to
transparency international it is the
second most corrupt country in europe
well that's just the beginning in the
index of economic freedom ukraine ranks
130 out of 177 it is placed alongside
countries such as uganda india and
alexander lukashenko's belarus in the
human freedom index it ranks 98th
practically on par with burkina faso
kazakhstan and mozambique in the rule of
law index which measures judicial
quality it ranked 74th in the press
freedom index 106th and in the
democratic quality index 86 in other
words whichever way you look at it
ukraine is a long way away from the
european club and yes thanks to the
association agreement they are not
starting from scratch but the road ahead
is long it's very long mind you we're
not only talking about applying european
regulations that would not be enough in
ukraine why want to know exactly what
pitfalls ukraine is facing well stay
tuned
[Music]
a colossal challenge
once the war is over and ukraine can
focus 100 on its reconstruction in every
sense physically economically socially
and politically the government of the
day will have to turn the country upside
down to meet the requirements for the
accession to the european union and it
will have to do so on a lot of fronts at
the same time it will of course have to
implement the reforms demanded by
brussels but it will also have to get
the country back on its feet starting of
course with the basic infrastructure
itself it is evident that a country that
is physically and institutionally
destroyed would find it practically
impossible to enter the european union
no matter what reforms it makes it would
simply be too expensive that is why when
the war is over ukrainian government
will have to strive not only to comply
with eu legislation and brussels
requests it will also have to act on
these two fronts
[Music]
according to ukrainian government
estimates rebuilding bridges basic
infrastructure and buildings alone will
require between 100 billion dollars and
200 billion dollars and if we add to
this the recovery of ukraine's economic
and productive fabric the total bill
could be well over 500 or 600 billion
[Music]
obviously this is something that
brussels cannot ignore when considering
a candidate for joining the european
union in other words that at the end of
the day european institutions will have
to implement a sort of marshall plan to
support reconstruction
the european union will create a
platform for the reconstruction of
ukraine the platform will be used to
determine investment needs coordinate
action and channel resources wanderlion
said the challenge here is to get this
recovery plan implemented without the
money ending up in the pockets of the
oligarchs who have controlled the
country's economy since the fall of the
soviet union because obviously if the
european union allocates a lot of money
which then serves no purpose that would
make the assession process very very
difficult brussels seems confident that
keeve will carry out a comprehensive
economic liberalization program but will
it really do so that remains to be seen
all in all it is not the most difficult
thing to do
the most difficult thing is that ukraine
will have to completely change its
nature as a country as we have already
said it will have to implement community
legislation but that is not enough it
will also have to put an end to the
stratospheric corruption and for example
it will have to create among many other
things a new judicial system that is
truly protective
all this visual politic fans is much
easier said than done how could ukraine
make a u-turn will the oligarchs allow
it and remember we're talking about a
country that has hundreds and hundreds
and thousands millions of young
immigrants all over europe young people
with professional skills and in many
cases good academic training young
people who could play a key role in the
process of economic and institutional
reconstruction that the country needs to
carry out before it can accede to the
european union in fact let's be clear
without attracting the diaspora back it
will be very difficult for ukraine to
achieve the level of prosperity wealth
and development necessary to complete
its accession to the european union in a
reasonable period of time but of course
in order for them to be able to return
invest or set up companies two things
are needed above all legal certainty and
open markets the question is how could
these two things be achieved
well some say that one way to achieve
this would be to emulate the model of
dubai's special economic zones as in the
case of the dubai international
financial center there british judges
train other judges and impart justice
following a special legal framework a
framework of law that is very protective
and very attractive to foreign companies
and investors now is this realistic and
is there even a remote possibility that
it will even be possible well probably
not but cases like that of oligarch
rinat akhmetov paradoxically do give
some hope akhmetov for those of you who
don't know him is the richest man in
ukraine and a businessman who always had
close connections to russia and the
pro-russian mileage of ukrainian
politics in fact he has been the main
financier and shadow leader of the
russophile party of regions with which
he became a lawmaker in the virk
hovnerada well pay attention to this
statement
evil cannot go unpunished russia's
crimes against ukraine and our people
are egregious and those guilty of them
must be held liable this lawsuit is one
of the first international legal steps
against russia to stop their ongoing
crimes destruction of the ukrainian
economy and the plundering of ukrainian
assets renat akhmanitov ukrainian
oligarch whether for money for a future
in ukraine or for a sudden love of his
homeland or for all of these things at
once the rhetoric of akhmetov owner
among many other things of the famous
azov still steel works has changed
radically
[Music]
well like him many other pro-russian
oligarchs are suffering multi-million
dollar losses due to the russian
invasion without going any further
akmetov's wealth has shrunk from its
peak of 16 billion dollars in 2012 to
about 4.2 billion
four times less according to forbes data
but as contradictory as it may seem this
situation could have a positive side
many of the big ukrainian oligarchs have
seen a significant proportion of their
productive assets shattered by russia
and with them much of their ability to
influence local communities and national
politics
in other words the destruction of much
of their wealth and influence together
with international assistance and
keeve's change of priorities may lead
these oligarchs to accept changes in the
rules of the game in order to become
entrepreneurs in a competitive market
keep in mind that if keeve really wants
to join the european union it is going
to have to put a stop to all of these
oligarchs let us say that it is very
likely that reconstruction social
pressure and now national security will
be worth much much much more than the
bribes and pressures of these oligarchs
oligarchs who in addition will have to
atone for their past pro-russian
leanings so it would not be strange to
see them suddenly flying the flag of the
european union and reforms
in short in order to become a full
member of the european union ukraine
will have to become a democracy of
certain quality it will have to adopt a
free market economy it will have to
introduce into its law and then apply
the very extensive european legislation
it will have to rebuild its
infrastructure it will have to promote
significant growth rates and end the
power of the oligarchs and completely
change its institutions a very long and
very very complicated to-do list but
wait a minute because it's not just
about ukraine in order to admit such a
large and troubled country as a full
member the european union itself may
have to change i am referring for
example to things like unanimity rules
you see in many areas the european union
requires the unanimity of all member
countries in order to be able to move
forward with various initiatives the
problem is that the european union is
becoming so big that this is becoming
increasingly complicated especially when
we take into account the enormous
differences that exist between the
member countries and to top it all off
ukraine would be a powerful ally of
poland a country that has not been
getting along particularly well with
brussels lately
and keep in mind that this is a risk
that some european leaders are already
talking about openly be that as it may i
think you can see ukraine's entry into
the european union if it ever happens
will be a very long process a very
difficult one and one that is subject to
many conditions but at this point it's
your turn do you think ukraine will
eventually join the european union and
will keeve manage to carry out all the
political and economic reforms necessary
to make ukraine a country that can
compete with eu members leave us your
questions below in the comments and of
course your answers as well and if you
liked this video don't forget to like
and subscribe to our channel so you
don't miss any news once again thank you
so much for being there all the best and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you